tonight we are thrilled to welcome
Prince Harry the Duke of Sussex Roger
Arena gets the Royal
Treatment Prince Harry and his wife
Megan the Canuck's newest fans in town
ahead of the 2025 Invictus games here in
BC it was fantastic they're very excited
they love British Columbia I represent
Sanic they stayed in North Sanic we had
a lot of conversations about the
Clubhouse sandwich that uh the Duke
enjoyed while he stayed there um they
can't wait to bring their family back
the Duke of susex following in his late
grandmother's footsteps Queen Elizabeth
II who dropped the park 21 years
earlier first up on the Royal itinerary
Whistler set to host the Invictus game's
first ever winter Edition using that to
address a different cohort of wounded
injured and sick we've got for example
you know a new nation Nigeria um coming
to do winter sports I mean that that's
taking them completely into a different
place it's offering them opportunity
they never thought they'd have um and
and I think there's a real excitement
around that hosted in partnership with
the Region's four First Nations how we
can build uh our community and make it
stronger not just with the indigenous
peoples but you know United with our
communities there's so much potential to
for True reconciliation
the Invictus games will see more than
500 competitors from over 20 Nations
descend on Vancouver and Whistler we're
still more than 14 months out but hype
is already building in the volunteer
program I mean just since last night
since the kuks game um uh 98 people have
registered for the volunteer program the
power of sport and a royal veteran with
a vision to bring communities together
Cassidy Moscone Global
News